§ 1 absatz 2 der geschäftsordnung des
deutschen bundestags sieht vor dass das
am längsten dem bundestag angehörende
mitglied das hierzu bereit ist den
vorsitz übernimmt bis der deutsche
bundestag eine präsidentin oder einen
präsidenten gewählt hat die fraktion der
afw widerspricht dieser praxis und hat
beantragt dass in der ersten sitzung des
bundestags das an jahren älteste
mitglied den vorsitz führt wird das wort
gewünscht herr kollege baumann
bernd baumann der erste parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der fdp fraktion jetzt
zu einem antrag der eine entscheidung
von vier jahren revidieren soll
herr präsident meine damen und herren
heute konstituiert sich ein neuer
bundestag und seit bald zwei
jahrhunderten ist es fester
parlamentarischer brauch dass ein so
genannter alterspräsident diese erste
sitzung eröffnet und das war immer aus
respekt vor dem alter der älteste
abgeordnete von allen von der
frankfurter paulskirche bis zum
parlament des kaiserreichs von der
weimarer republik bis zum
wiedervereinigten deutschland sogar bis
tief hinein in die regierungszeit
merkels alle reichstag alle bundestage
hielten sich an diese regel in fast zwei
jahrhunderten hat nur ein parlament es
gewagt mit dieser tradition zu brechen
das war man muss es deutlich sagen 1933
nach der machtergreifung mit einem
präsidenten hermann göring soll dass ihr
vorbild sein davor hatte ich so
davor hatte sie 2017 schon gewarnt dass
es keine gute tradition kommen sie
wieder zurück auf den seit jahrhunderten
bewährten weg aller deutschen demokraten
war so wollen sie diese regel warum
wollen sie diese regel heute wieder
durchbrechen ist doch klar wie vor vier
jahren kommt auch heute der älteste und
erfahrenste abgeordnete und damit der
legitime alterspräsident aus den reihen
der afg akzeptieren sie das erkennen sie
dass endlich an
und es gibt noch einen grund warum sie
sich weigern noch ein grund in der
älteste und erfahrenste in diesem neu
gewählten parlament ist
alexander gauland über ein halbes
jahrhundert in der deutschen politik
auch an führenden stellen 40 jahre davon
in der cdu und in den vergangenen vier
jahren der mächtigste und
wortgewaltigsten oppositionsführer hier
im hause meine damen und herren
den legitimen alterspräsidenten gauland
wollen sie verhindern
genauso wie beim amtes vizepräsident
auch das verweigern sie uns seit vielen
jahren ein wichtiges ein zentrales amt
dass alle anderen fraktionen bekommen
und das laut der geschäftsordnung auch
der afg zusteht beides die verweigerung
des alltags präsidenten wie auch des
vize präsidenten ist nicht nur eine
missachtung der afd als
gleichberechtigte fraktion hier im hause
schlimmer noch
es ist auch eine missachtung eine
herabsetzung von millionen wählern eine
beleidigung jedes einzelnen eine
verhöhnung der demokratie
meine damen und herren
umgang von regierung und
parlamentsmehrheit mit der opposition
zeigt sich der zustand einer demokratie
eigentlich müsste die eu kommission
umgehend ein rechtsstaat verfahren
eröffnet nicht gegen ungarn nicht gegen
polen meine damen und herren sondern
gegen deutschland wegen offensichtlicher
und fortgesetzter benachteiligung der
opposition in diesem haus
wir werden nachher noch sehen wie es
weitergeht bei der wahl des
vize-präsidenten mit michael kaufmann
tritt ein sehr renommierter
hochschulprofessor an selbst der linke
ministerpräsident in thüringen hat ihn
gewählt und nicht mal frau merkel bei
claas rückgängig gemacht
jörn baumann der erste parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der fdp-fraktion zu
seinem antrag carsten schneider der
erste parlamentarische geschäftsführer
der spd-fraktion mit seiner gegenrede
sondern gleich gesagt
herr präsident zierke der damen und
herren heute ist in der tat ein
besonderer tag für die demokratie
nach der wahl einmal des deutschen
volkes stehen wir heute hier als
abgeordnete des deutschen bundestages um
uns als bundestag zu konzentrieren von
diesem bundestag geht die macht in
deutschland aus weil wir werden die ein
jahr die andern 1 1 bundeskanzlerin und
dazu gibt es das erneuerung dass es
gehört aber auch zur demokratie hier
dazu und zeichnet sie aus dass drei
parteien miteinander eine koalition
anstreben die bisher noch nie
miteinander korreliert haben und es
zeichnet diese fraktion diesen bundestag
und dieses land aus dass eine partei
große partei die lange an der macht war
dies friedlich fair über gibt nämlich
die unionsfraktion und möchte mich ganz
besonders bei der unionsfraktion für die
faire zusammenarbeit der letzten jahre
bedanken vielen dank
ich sage das
bevor ich zur habt ihr dem antrag komme
auch in richtung der amtierenden
bundeskanzlerin auch noch den minister
nicht sehr minister halt mal hier den
ich vor wenigen tagen angerufen habe als
leider arbeitsgruppe wirtschaft um mit
ihnen darüber zu sprechen welche dinge
und mit geben kann und dass er uns auch
das haus eröffnet für informationen das
geschieht das ist demokratie das ist
demokratie in deutschland scherer
übergabe von macht akzeptanz von
wahlergebnis und die liebe auf die sie
haben die wahl verloren
sie haben an stimmen verloren an
zustimmung in deutschland und es gehört
dazu dass dieser bundestag diese
abkommen sich eine geschäftsordnung
geben und das ist auch der unterschied
zur wahl blick die sie sich herr baumann
erdreistet taten hier zu zitieren
erdreistet haben ja dahin reist der
hilfe eine frechheit
die weimarer republik über
fassung war gut es war nur zu wenig
demokraten die sie unterstützt haben und
zwar zu viele die sie von innen heraus
bekämpft und informiert haben und ihre
truppe dazu gehört die ihre vorgänger
hat dazu gehört
wir schlagen vor der star dass präsident
so wichtig geschäftsordnung ersetzen
bundestages vorgesehen hat derjenige ist
der an dienstjahren die meiste zeit hier
im bundestag verbracht hat und ich
könnte mir ich könnte mir gar keinen
besseren alterspräsidenten vorstellen
als doktor wolfgang schäuble
ich habe ihn persönlich schätzen gelernt
als der bundesfinanzminister
in der euro-krise habe ihn schätzen
gelernt hier eine zusammenarbeit als
präsident und niemand verfügt über super
erfahrung um diese erste sitzung des
bundestages zu beginn zu leiten und an
fairen übergang zu garantieren von daher
wir lehnen ihren antrag strikt ab und
sind für herrn schäuble hinter
carsten schneider für die spd-fraktion
mit 206 abgeordneten die stärkste in
dieser legislaturperiode und wir sehen
schon michael grosse brömer auf dem weg
den ersten parlamentarischen
geschäftsführer der unions-fraktion als
alterspräsident kann ich auf die
einhaltung der geschäftsordnung nicht so
drängend wie ich die letzten vier jahre
getragen haben also überfordern sie mich
bitte nicht bitte er grosse brömer
herr präsident lieber
herr baumann nur weil sie herrn bauland
vorgeschlagen haben wer die dunkelste
das dunkelste kapitel unserer geschichte
als als fliegenschiss bezeichnet der hat
sich schon dadurch disqualifiziert hier
jemals als retter skeptisch
bei der afg
bei der afg ist immer viel von
ausgrenzung die rede und auch
sondern
vogels ist macht die sache jetzt
ausnahmsweise nicht besser aber vielen
dank für den hinweis
die einzige ausgrenzung die hier
stattfindet ist die selbstausgrenzung
aus den reihen der afd
insbesondere von denen die überzeugte
parlamentarier sind wir haben die
vergangenen vier jahre erlebt und
eigentlich haben sie nicht unversucht
verlassen gelassen dieses diesem
parlament zu schaden und deswegen ist
auch ihr antrag heute den gerade wieder
nicht besser insbesondere und das ist
die kontinuität in ihrem vorgehen er ist
wieder schlampig begründet da steht zum
beispiel die regelung zum
alterspräsidenten würden kolleginnen und
kollegen aus den neuen ländern
benachteiligen weil diese erst nach 1990
kandidieren konnten wenn sie jetzt mal
in die liste der
dienstältesten kolleginnen und kollegen
geschaut hätten was sie im gegensatz zu
mir offenbar nicht getan haben dann
stellen sie fest dass nach wolfgang
schäuble nur mitglieder folgen die nach
1990 in diesem bundestag eingezogen sind
also ist das schon in der sache völlig
unschlüssig im übrigen folgt an dritter
stelle der kollege gregor gysi also eine
schlechterstellung der ostdeutschen
kolleginnen und kollegen ist für mich
jetzt nicht spontan erkennbar
auch dass man diese jetzt
wie wäre es auch wieder eine andere
geschichte aber es ist erst mal so und
herr doktor schäuble ich möchte die
gelegenheit nutzen zu sagen die regelung
des alterspräsidenten hat sich bewährt
es ist eine besondere freude dass sie
heute als alterspräsident diese sitzung
eröffnet haben ich möchte die
gelegenheit nutzen in meiner im namen
meiner fraktion herzlich dank zu sagen
für ihre tätigkeit als
bundestagspräsident in den letzten
jahren sie haben dieses amt besonnen
unparteiisch und würdig ausgeführt sie
haben die bundestag vor angriffen von
außen und von innen verteidigt und in
war vor allem der fairer ausgleich von
mehrheit und opposition immer ein
besonderes anliegen dafür herzlichen
dank und
als letztes kurz der hinweis weil wir
gerade von fairem ausgleich von mehrheit
und opposition sprechen und carsten
schneider den ich auch herzlich danke
für die gute zusammenarbeit in den
letzten jahren das haben wir auch gut
hingekriegt und jetzt sind wir ein
anderer positionen mal gucken wie es
läuft aber ich glaube wir haben gute
grundlagen gemeinsam weiterhin
vernünftig zu arbeiten wenn aber der
fähre übergang gemeint ist den ich mir
auch wünsche dann möchte ich gerade mit
blick auf fairen ausgleichs von mehrheit
und opposition sagen gleich nach der
wahl eine traditionelle sitzordnung im
plenum mit der brechstange ändern zu
wollen finde ich es nicht gut gespielt
und ich
spüre ein haus von arroganz der macht
aber ich bin auch überzeugt
ich bin überzeugt dass die opposition
insbesondere die liberalen so klug sind
davon abzusehen traditionelle
geflogenheiten dieses parlamentes aus
eigennutz und kaum in der mehrheits lage
mal zu ändern auch wieder absehen ich
bin da sehr sicher ich setze auf die
einsichtsfähigkeit und klugheit der fdp
in dieser hinsicht bewährte tradition in
diesem hause zu erhalten die wir
kolleginnen und kollegen wir lehnen den
antrag der afd wie ich finde mit guten
gründen ab
gibt es weiter überhaupt meldungen das
ist nicht der fall dann lasse ich über
den antrag der fraktion der afc auf
drucksache zwei abstimmen wer stimmt für
den antrag der afd
wir sind dagegen
[Musik]
dann ist der abwehr enthält sich
das ist offenbar wie man dann ist der
antrag der afg gegen die stimme der asd
mit den stimmen des übrigen hauses
abgelehnt und damit verbleibt es dabei
dass nach paragraf 1 absatz 2 der
geschäftsordnung das am längsten dem
bundestag angehörende mitglied den
vorsitz übernimmt und michael grosse
brömer hat eben schon eindrucksvoll
dargelegt dass offensichtlich ich das
bin also freue ich mich den vorsitz zu
übernehmen und zugleich für künftig für
kommende falls noch
geschäftsordnungsdebatte hinzu dass ich
ab jetzt wieder darauf achte dass bei
reden zur geschäftsordnung wirklich nur
bis zur geschäftsordnung des brauchen
wird